are republicans the party of the working
class while dems are the party of the
pompous ass
[Laughter]
as damned elites lean lefty the price
they're paying is hefty according to
axios the website not my greek personal
trainer who went missing with my enya
cds
democrats are becoming the party of
upscale voters while republicans are
quietly building a multiracial coalition
of working-class voters yep the
republicans are building a tent that's
big enough for barack obama's birthday
party
axios calls it a political realignment
in real time meanwhile dems just assume
these brown and black people must be
white supremacists
it's a shift that political watchers who
are like bird watchers but with fewer
friends
say will benefit the right in the
midterms especially as more hispanics
flock to the gop proving they're losing
interest in woke cultural issues that
ignore real life concerns plus the right
won't compare them to breakfast tacos
although they are delicious
meantime the american federation of
teachers commissioned a poll they
thought would paint liberals in a good
light they asked voters if they have
more confidence in dems or republicans
in dealing with education republicans
got 39 percent of the vote compared to
38 for the dems
only a one-point advantage but that's
not bad for a poll that's rigged by a
teacher's union
no wonder no wonder they don't want to
give parents a choice
but with the midterms closing in dems
are desperate to overhaul their elitist
image i wonder how that's going to go
thanks for coming to this focus group
everyone as a democrat i just want to
touch base with average voters you know
you dirty fingernail types gas prices
are pretty bad
yeah no very concerning have you tried
maybe taking the boat out only twice a
year i don't own a boat
well not with that attitude
i'm worried about feeding my family you
just don't get it
maybe you're right
maybe
we are out of touch
we're the party of jfk and fdr
not aoc
now on we'll put the concerns of
hard-working american families first
oh my god hello
of course i'll i'll be there right away
i've got a 4pm tea time at the country
club i gotta go shannon call my uber
yeah those damn uber-using commies
[Music]
[Laughter]
douglas
do you think this is real or is this
wishful thinking is this happening this
transition
well clearly the left that axios
headline sort of speaks to that isn't
that they're just horrified whenever
they discover that like ethnic
minorities might vote republican they
can't understand it they think have they
not been told often enough by us the
left-wing media that this is just voting
for the kkk don't they get it yet uh so
of course then they make those people
like honorary white americans
and and whenever they discover that
amazingly some women vote republican
they become men and there's just a set
of sort of games they never take it
seriously they never actually take the
concerns of voters seriously anything
you know maybe there's something we're
doing wrong maybe there's something
we're not speaking to it's always maybe
we haven't told them off enough right
it's
we're the ones that fall tyrus it seems
like when they get into power their only
pursuit is more power and not the needs
of the voters well it's the the needs of
the few the individuals outweigh the
question and i don't i don't think it's
fair to democrats i think moderate
democrats are kind of stuck yeah like
you know because it's just like if our
fringe suddenly started driving the bus
we would all have very different
conversations on this show right true
and they're not only driving the bus
they're also deciding who gets on the
bus so if you're not in line and in tow
with what they've got you can't be a
part of it and that excludes just about
everybody but their little group or
whoever they've decided to be that's why
when you see them come after people
there's never giant
hordes of protesters behind them they
rely on the twitter as their shadow band
that that goes after people so yeah i
think working class because the only
ones whether but here's the thing
republicans we have to do something with
it right we are saying yes we're here
for parents yes we're here for schools
yes we're going to get this down in gas
prices and we're talking a good game but
let's say november we have the blue
drowning and we get all we get a big red
wave in there and we don't do anything
that we talked about this is going to be
topsy-turvy all over again so we're in a
good position right now to actually get
some things done because the american
people are listening to who's going to
do what's best for my dinner table not
what i call my wife at the dinner table
whatever pronoun that is or whatever we
don't give a damn what you call me make
sure there's food on my table that's the
whole thing is that they're they've
they've replaced the desire the needs of
the working class for uh um identity
politics they want name tags on
everybody instead of meeting people yeah
that good point there
uh cat you hail from a working class
background am i right
no my family's loaded
sorry you've never been invited on our
luxury yet
yeah i think the democrats have just
made it like too easy for republicans
like for example with education right
for the longest time education was such
a nuanced debate of you know what kids
should be learning in school what they
should be focusing on what was the role
of school in certain areas versus not
and then during covid the democrats
turned it into a bait with two sides
which was the kids should go to school
versus no
you can't be shocked when people are
going to think school's good for kids
yeah so i again like tyrus says i really
think that they've made it pretty easy
but republicans have to be careful to
not try to counter oh every single thing
that they you know pull up all these
different issues be it you know these
different social issues or identity
politics and not try to aggressively
specifically counter those and focus on
the things that everybody does that it's
a fair point that leave that stuff to
clowns like me
right sure because like talking about
the the the pronouns and the trans stuff
is fun
but you the republicans should just be
focusing on crime and inflation the
economy the you know that kind of stuff
that you know frankly bores the people
at home
i'm kidding um
does this shifted demographic surprise
you i remember i heard you talking about
it on a podcast i think with michael
shermer about how the democrats uh
you're a democrat i believe right or
used to be well i call myself a lefty i
don't i don't know that i would call
myself a democrat especially not in this
room this crowd you know i won't make it
home
but
yeah no i think this shift has been
underway for a very long time you know
50 years ago the left and the democrats
were the side of of labor the side of
the working class and the republicans
the side of the rich today you've seen a
real shift in who each side sees as
their base and if you look at the
democrats platform it is a wish list for
like the over-educated top 10 percent
you know environmentalism and banning
fracking right like that is like vanity
morals for the for the wealthy that
punishes the working class it takes away
their jobs defunding the police like you
said greg a couple weeks ago on the five
that is doing the kkk's work for it
right that hurts working-class people of
color it ends up dead bodies piling up
but it makes them feel so good about
themselves and holier than thou right
because they don't have to worry about
crime in their neighborhoods because
they live in these upscale neighborhoods
the war in ukraine right let's fund that
fund that fund that gas is going up
right but it makes them feel good right
and because they're taking ubers they
don't care right they're taking the
subway they live in cities they don't
feel it like the working class and so
you see all of this entire agenda is
built around flattering the vanity of
liberal elites at the expense of the
working class and i totally love what
you both said which is this is this is
an opportunity for republicans not to
squander it you know not to just use it
to like win these cultural battles but
actually to make the lives of working
class and middle class americans better
excellent points
all right
and she watches the five
that's my warm-up show
kind of fun it's a little show but we we
do our best with what we have hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else